henri guaino à la conquête de l'elysée
le député de la 3e circonscription des
yvelines souhaite se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
sur ce chemin une étape aux chaînés pour
une séance de dédicaces et mobiliser ses
sympathisants eh bien ça avance avec
toutes les difficultés que vous pouvez
imaginer puisque tout le système est
fait pour que personne ne puisse venir
contester la loi des grands appareils
en tout cas moi je suis déterminé à
aller jusqu'au bout parce que je n'en
peux plus de faire de la politique en
acceptant de
la vie politique telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui plusieurs soutiens du député
illinois sont venus à sa rencontre pour
échanger
j'espérais qu'il allait enfin voler de
ses propres ailes et quitter le giron
des publications peut dire le débat
qu'on a actuellement dans les dents
certains partis politiques c'est de ces
de passer au dessus des clivages gauche
droite parce qu'il ya des choses très
bien à droite et les choses très bien à
gauche il faut il suffit maintenant il
faut maintenant il suffit mais il faut
surtout maintenant être intelligent
considérant le clivage gauche-droite
dépasser henri guaino souhaite bousculer
les lignes politiques avec des
propositions économiques pour lutter
contre le laisser faire aujourd'hui la
vraie image est entre ceux qui vous
disent il faut s'adapter
ce qui veut dire subir et ceux qui vous
disent ce qu'ils croient profondément
qu'il faut nous donner les moyens d'agir
dans le monde tel qu'il est est ce que
nous pensons vraiment que la concurrence
peut résoudre tous les problèmes de
l'économie de la société
est ce que c'est bien raisonnable mais
ce livre dit que non ce n'est pas
raisonnable sur le renouvellement de son
mandat de député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines henri
guaino prendra une décision après la
présidentielle de 2017